if the attack on the u.s capitol were to
happen again today thomas manger says
the newly revamped force could hold the
mob at bay
we didn't have the
people
we didn't act on the intelligence and we
just weren't prepared the way we should
have been and that that's going to
change that has changed and um and the
next time that we're tested um
we will not be making those same
mistakes
the inspector general for the force that
protects the u.s capital complex found
that during the january 6 2021 assault
one year ago officers had ignored
intelligence warnings that rioters might
attack the seat of government and when
they did officers were outnumbered
outmaneuvered and ill-equipped and while
i'm proud of our officers the events of
january 6 did expose critical
departmental failures and deficiencies
with operational planning intelligence
staffing training and equipment
manger an outsider brought in to
overhaul the capitol police told the
senate rules committee he's addressed 90
of 103 recommendations made by the
inspector general though it could take
three years to hire the 447 additional
officers it needs
across the u.s federal agents in nearly
every state are continuing to track down
the estimated 2500 rioters involved in
the attacks they're using 14 000 hours
of video from reporters surveillance
cameras and police body cameras
so far more than 700 people have been
charged
the justice department remains committed
to holding all january 6 perpetrators
at any level accountable under law
retired general russell honore who led a
house review of the failures of the
police on january 6 told us the force
was simply unprepared it was a total
failure government
that being said
the line officers and the d.c police
saved our democracy
but somehow
the trump defense department where he
had ripped out the qualified people and
put his own operators in there
found a way not to send the national
guard when they could have been there
earlier
we've got to get government straight
president biden is expected to address
the attack on its anniversary he will
forcibly push back on the lie spread by
the former president in an attempt to
mislead the american people and his own
supporters as well as distract from his
role and what happens that turns the
tables on the last president who sent
the mob to capitol hill in a speech that
perpetuated the lie that he not biden
actually won the 2020 election john
hendren al jazeera washington